thank you
[Music]
what kind of Airship is that I've never
seen anything like it baby clayed what
is the president doing in our front yard
our entire world is in grave danger I
want you to come with me on an
expedition
I'm not my father he was the Explorer I
know you were just a kid when he went
missing but now
you're all we got Mr Clay I'm a huge fan
thank you of your dad do you think you
could Forge his autograph what
where in the world are we
[Music]
brought the dog sorry
[Music]
we are clearly in Uncharted Territory
[Music]
[Applause]
hello you probably don't understand a
word I'm saying of course I understand
you
dad dad Grandpa I'm a grandpa what is
this place the cliffs are alive and the
waters dissolve the flesh off your bones
everything down here is trying to kill
us
[Music]
do you mind if I call you splat you just
kind of give me Splat Vibes
I guess I deserve that
Grandpa's awesome he is not awesome you
gave me a machete for my birthday a
classic Jager claimed I was too
I'm loving this family reunion but come
on we got a world to save
[Music]
I need you to figure this out otherwise
we're doomed we are doomed wait
seriously no I'm just messing with you
is that coming
[Music]
[Applause]